اعدام صدام حسين هل حضر ضباط مخابرات
ايرانيون
كم كان عددهم لماذا
اثناء صعود الرئيس الله يرحمه على يعني
الدرجه وصاعد على المنصه اتكلموا حتى
يثبتوه لانه احنا الحاكم تكلموا بالفارسي
حتى يوصلوا للرساله انه احنا اللي حكمناكم
يعني عقابا على حرب الثمان سنوات
بالفارسي تقول بالفارسي نعم كان حدا عم
يترجم له يعني لا لما حيترجم له بس هو من
الغايه كان اسمها صوت اللغه الفارسيه حتى
لو بدون ما يعني يفهم اللي هم الوصول
الوصوتهم باللغه الفارسيه خلص انه
ايرانيين موجودين واللغه الفارسيه معروفه
هل فعلا حضر قاسم سليماني اعدام صدام حسين
منصور الاعدام مريم الرئيس وموفق الربيعي
وهل كان يقولان امور معينه يعني اللي صدام
حسين او لغيره النفق الرباعي كان يعني
يشتم بالرئيس وكان خايف هو نفسه
هل صحيح انه عدد عقد الحبل حبل المشنقه
كان على عدد صواريخ التي ضربها صدام حسين
على اسرائيل هذا ما نقل من داخل قاعه
المحكمه قاعه الادم
39 39 نقطه
على عدد صواريخ التي قصف بها اسرائيل
هل مات شنقا فعلا
كانت عمليه اعدام عمليه غوائيه
يعني انت تؤكد لنا الشكوك حول
موته شنقا نعم عمليه غوغائيه عمليه اداما
من الاطلاق الشعارات الى التهديد الى اخر
مرحله
هو الذي رفض فعلا وضع الكيس نعم
عندما تقول غوغائيه يعني تتجاوز الشنق
هكذا تفسر
ماذا كان دور الضباط الايرانيين
ايصال رساله انه احنا اللي عدمك
في معلومات تقول انه كان عندهم اهداف اخرى
متعلقه بالتاكد من هويه من يقومون باعدامه
ربما
يعني اخذوا مثلا
اشياء معينه من جسده للدي ان اي للفحوص
لا اعتقد